we checked him out in college in Arizona
with coach Liu Dolson and we checked him
out for 11 seasons in the Association
and now you can check him out with new
episodes added every Monday to Thursday
at 2:00 p.m. Eastern on complex his
YouTube channel the co-host of
out-of-bounds Agent Zero and hibachi
himself Gilbert Arenas good to see you
sir thank you for having me how's life
life is good yeah life is good you know
I again I'm on a out of bound and at
2:00 p.m. Eastern yes it gave me a
chance to come back and be a part of the
sports world again it's part of the
would you miss you miss just being part
just being part of it you know when you
dedicate your whole life to you know
perform in teammates the crowd and then
when you get out a spot like you kind of
miss a little bit yeah I know a lot of
it's that it's the the issue of being
somebody that you know for years as an
athlete right and then not many
businesses do you need to find a second
act in your mid-30s right I mean it's
it's really you know it's certainly when
you excel at something I mean the NFL
the average Chris four years old yeah I
feel I feel sorry for them because it's
there's 55 of you guys right you know
just bonding every day and you guys are
with you're with each other more than
you are with your actual families right
you know when when that when that career
is over I'm pretty sure it's hard on
them Gilbert Arenas here in the Rich
Eisen [ __ ] was the best player you
played with with with I can't say myself
so you must remove your um I'll say
Antoine Jamison really yes that is not
the name that I would have expected to
come out of your mouth okay white Howard
but you know he was still he was still
young you know he didn't you know I had
a half a season with him so I didn't
really get that right see his greatness
but I seen it coming you know before the
back injury but you know Antoine
Jamerson Antoine Jameson jr. mr. 20 and
10 ok mr. t I guess he was he was that
and and when you take a look at the NBA
right now how do you see this season
playing out do you see Houston being
able to beat Golden State when it all
comes down to it because that seems to
be the biggest drama
left two this season right now and when
it comes to regular season I put no
bearing on it because though the style
you play has no bearing in playoffs so
Houston style with James Harden
basically plan ISO basketball every
possession he gets it I don't know how
that works
in the playoffs especially if you play a
team like San Antonio first you know
who-who was a half-court defensive team
so you know depending on what the
matchups are can be problematic for for
Houston for you so but you don't see how
they've played so far this year that
harden capela and Chris Paul now have
only two losses after Toronto took care
of their winning streak I mean you don't
see because it because of the way the
schedule is you know you have three
games four games in you know in seven
days it's hard to actually set up a game
plan against Houston and just like you
know Golden State when they won 72
they're moving so fast as hard to really
if I'm playing Houston today Toronto
tomorrow you you you're not really game
planning for these guys so once the
playoff comes you get to sit down and
say okay when James Harden goes right
he's gonna step back 95 percent at a
time when he goes left he's got a twin
tween tweent tweenty end drive so I mean
you get to break that down in the
playoffs not in regular C ha so you
don't so you think when it's all said
and done Houston might not even get to
the Western Conference Finals because if
that's the case I mean it depends on
what it depends on what the road is of
course you know it's all matchups you
know I know let's figure this out right
now right now it would be Denver could
be Houston it could be I mean it could
be Santa you know host of any eight sees
that they see but let's just even move
on I mean if it is Houston Oklahoma City
we just saw them destroy Oklahoma City
moments but that's the team up I
wouldn't want to play in the playoffs
because they have Houston has two stars
with Chris Paul and James Harden OKC has
two stars which are third being Carmelo
if you shut down those two you still
have a Carmelo Anthony who can possibly
score 40 a night and carry that team
that's what makes that team scary in a
playoffs because you have three guys who
can
for 40 a night Houston has two Golden
State has three in a possible guy who
can score 17 with draymond Green so it
comes to star power you know when you're
keen in and taking a player out what
players going to step up and you know
you take out James Harden
you know if Chris Paul is scoring 40
your team is not that good because that
means he's not passing to everybody else
Gilbert Arenas here on the Rich Eisen
show so when LeBron makes a decision of
where he goes next should he do what you
did which is flip a coin
did you really flip a coin where you
were going but I thought I think
mentally I already was choosing
Washington because it did land on
clippers and I usually do the opposite
of what hold on a second okay so this is
you three for you right this is you're
in the NBA
alright and you have a choice to go
wherever you want to go and you take out
what corner a quarter dime what do you
got a quarter here's a quarter uh-huh
and then you flipped it and it came up
whatever side was for the Clippers yes
it came out Clippers Clippers as a head
and then I said okay I usually do the
opposite of what I supposed to do so I'm
going Washington so if it came up tells
you to go to the Clippers I don't know I
don't know I probably should probably
what it still went to Washington because
it was just it was just a new start you
know there was no legit star in
Washington at the time right so you know
I just felt it was better than staying
home and have to worry about tickets and
all that friends right so you go to the
East Coast you go to Washington yeah
Gilbert Arenas here in the Rich Eisen
show let's get into it what what
happened to you in Washington Gilbert
which part okay the good part in the bad
part the part that kind of derailed your
career a little bit Gilbert it was
injury okay it was it was injured I got
I had three surgeries in 14 months okay
you know and I was unuseful anymore what
a big contract so therefore they needed
to define any kind of way to get rid of
that contract and that's why it was me
pulling a gun on my teammate instead of
it being opposite
and that's what it was it was the
opposite around and I was never near a
gun or never touched a gun but didn't
you did not bring one into your locker
room at the okay it's like you never
touched it I get it I get to the gym
eight o'clock in the morning we have
practice at 11:00 so I'm there before
anyone yes so no one could have no one
no one was there to the the see me touch
again mm-hmm so I just put on a shirt
told him to pick one okay huh all right
so what I guess what would you what
would you have told you yourself back
then that you know right now is the Cara
Gilbert Arenas
what would you have told that person
that was getting into an issue it with
with a teammate it was okay over what by
the way before you answer that question
over nothing it was it's a sports thing
it's like when someone says you're gonna
do something I'm gonna pull your Bluff
card that's you know that's just the
that's just that athletes mind said you
tell them they can't do something gonna
do it so it was one of those things
where you know my teammate Sadie was
gonna do something and I was like oh let
me see it so I'll bring you two guns and
I want to see you you know do what
you're gonna do to me and that's what
that was on my side you know so it was
more of a I'm just pulling his bluff
card right and it just went south
because because you think the team
wanted to get out of his car out of your
contract yes see a felony a felony when
I got out of my contract which I did
plead guilty to you don't know why I was
it was everything was moving so fast so
I just pleaded guilty to you know just I
thought I was gonna because my lawyer
told me that if you plead guilty you
will have to go to court so it was one
of those things like it was everything
was just moving so fast so I was like
all right guilty let's just get this
thing over with if I did any jail time
they can get off my contract so rumor
was they were really pissed that I
didn't get jail time they're gonna get
off my contract I don't mean to laugh
but I mean the way you're the way you're
describing it you know I mean I tell
people if you look at my um if you look
at what I got suspended for yes has no
mention of guns
just judgmental to the team so what
would you tell that Gilbert Arenas back
then no I didn't know now is your
current version Gilbert Arenas I mean
the obvious answer to say oh don't bring
should you know a gun sort of locker
room but I can't say I would tell myself
that we had paintball shootings in a in
in a locker rooms you know people
carried guns in a locker room stored him
in a locker room like if you did an NBA
sweep right now you still find a gun in
a locker room you would yeah especially
I want a satyr Friday Saturday night yes
because our arenas are downtown and most
people live on the outskirts so when
they go to party they have their weapons
instead of going to the club with it
yeah put it in their locker and then
that's how they travel so it in their
car under the arena which is still part
of the arena you know so so a gun charge
in the NBA was three to seven games
which I was in the one to three area but
it was so big that you couldn't suspend
me for one or three games so I got
suspended for detrimental to the team
because of a stretcher and they said I
wasn't mentally stable and they get to
hold that as long as they want and
that's what Davis urn did Gilbert Arenas
here on the Rich Eisen show all right
let's move to the current day here out
of bounds what what do you want people
to know about this program if they
already haven't caught it now that new
episodes are being added right I call it
a real take on sports in a joking way
you know I got Adam Caporal as one of
the co-hosts damn I can't even remember
your name we got Peter Sims in Pierce
Simpson
that's my guy and I couldn't remember
his name right you know what I with Joe
Brockman over there all the time there's
three sports guys and we just get the
talk sports mmm in any language we
decide fits mm-hmm you know and it's
like that like what ESPN and other
sports shows if you have to if you have
to gar
what you're saying and you really can't
give truth too much so you just
basically out there just going through
the motion I mean you just spat you know
you you you didn't stutter with some of
your answers here on this show so it's a
little glimpse of what's on on a complex
YouTube channel you with Adam Caporal
and Pierre Simpson every single Thursday
at 2:00 Eastern Time
it called world's most dangerous sports
show it's it gets it gets there we
always used to joke on SportsCenter you
know back in the day when I was there
late 90s that we would love to have done
a pay-per-view SportsCenter well we
thought of where we could have just
thought worked blue said whatever the
hell was on the top of our mind it and
that's what we get to do we were
sponsored by ESPN ABC in bed wins this
show we had to copy down the only wild
ride they'd made like is mr. Toad's
that's pretty much whatever what you go
ahead ask him the question good yeah go
after you sign that huge deal there was
a lot of rumors about the house you were
building like two Grotto's and a fish
tank got a shark tank whatever happened
to all that stuff know that I bought
that house of the first contract built
the pool on the first kind of track did
all that on the first contract okay I
ended up selling it 2012 I just felt
that was never gonna go back to DC so I
end up selling it I lost money of course
a shark shark tank there was an actual
tank with it was a shark tank yeah I
just something about sharks I just I was
there every shark in there I didn't even
know I know I know it was it was a
little black tips
okay very good I had to tear I had to
tear I had to tear it actually I had to
tear it down because you know people who
are buying a house they probably don't
have the same passion to my good friends
or Wizards fans so they wanted me to ask
okay so again three-time all-star
co-host of complex is out of bounds
check it out on YouTube complexes
YouTube channel every single Monday to
Thursday
new episodes at 2:00 Eastern Time we're
about to see a glimpse of it for the
television only audience good to see you
I think you think about Agent Zero here
on the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience